depuis plusieurs années les réseaux
sociaux sont devenus une source
d'information essentielle réactive
féroce disponible à la publication 24
heures sur 24 c'est souvent par là
aujourd'hui que les affaires sortent et
que les scandales éclatent
si les fakes news sont légions de plus
en plus de comptes en ligne public des
infos qui s'avère souvent exact ces
derniers temps la presse people s'est à
plusieurs reprises fait prendre de court
par les réseaux sociaux des informations
presque en temps réel qui interroge sur
l'utilité d'une presse people
traditionnel disponibles chaque semaine
sur papier on se souvient par exemple de
l'altercation musclée entre goobye
cariste à l'aéroport d'orly les images
avaient d'abord fuité sur les réseaux
sociaux avant de se retrouver dans la
presse people car en plus des
investigateurs en ligne aujourd'hui les
stars dévoile par elles mêmes dans leur
story ou leur publication en ligne des
photos de leurs familles de leurs
week-ends ou de leur maison plus besoin
donc de paparazzi planquer pour
découvrir les coulisses de la vie de nos
stars préférées un changement
significatif que la rédactrice en chef
du magazine voici reconnaît internet et
l'avenir de la presse people ces
dernières années les chiffres de ventes
de ses titres people semble s'effondrer
plus rapidement que les journaux
traditionnels
alors selon vous les réseaux sociaux
ont-ils tué la presse people est votre
avis nous intéresse ici à beaucoup
vous cruciaux puis la presse people et
deux noms quand même juste trois golden
the donald approuve a quand même parlé
un paparazzi et bien pour toi non la
presse les réseaux sociaux sont pas en
train de tuer la presse people et
pourtant qu'il a vécu non parce qu'il
faut pas tout confondre
parce que il ya un an on peut parler de
l'internet qui tue le print c'est à dire
le magazine papier
ouais mais il ya toujours des lecteurs
pour les contenus people je vais vous
prendre l'exemple des états unis où
avant il y avait neuf magazine l'a
quasiment plus inquiets vivent
aujourd'hui ou en bon état mais ça
n'empêche pas des sites énorme d'attirer
plus de lecteurs qu'il y en avait avant
c'est à dire que les contenus people aux
états unis sont plus importants et les
paparazzi américains n'ont aucun mal à
vendre leurs photos à ces sites là et
même plus chanavat d'accord donc voilà
pienaar revanche les sites people car
les gros sites donc la balance s'est
fait aux états unis donc ne sont pas
d'accord en france parce que la france
en france la balance la balance ne se
fera pas à cause de problèmes juridiques
mais les réseaux sociaux en attendant
elles ne sortent pas de scoop sur i les
taux d'intérêt dont le travail était en
train de me dire c'est bon scoop mais
elle nous avait tous quand on est coach
cameron diaz el had ont subitement
qu'elle a fait son enfant à 47 mais
s'est pas décidée par un scoop ça mais
alors moi je parle de free reggane
quitte la royauté il annonce l'istat
grave mais je passe je parle de scooter
volé mais les seconds couteaux le génial
de priyanka chopra et de et du fils
jonas écoute ses habitants tout les tout
ça c'est ce qu'ont photo c'est tous des
trucs qu'on aurait ça y va avec ces
photos soient cédés exclusivité que ben
exclusivité photo c'est ce qu'on mettait
en tenant avait décidé on est ce que
vous venez de sébastien beaucoup parlent
de son bilan ce que veut dire le luxe et
que pour eux s'ils auraient été les
coiffes de magazines n'est pas un scoop
la mariage comme établir et des photos
non c'est la côte il parle effectivement
de scouts guides de quel people de
quelques politiques gpra la sas à
s'arrêter c'est pas d'exclusivité ça
s'arrêtait des unes de magazines comme
jonas mais oui parce que regarder qu'à
brandir les croqueurs de seine
on a fait des photos de ce mariage qu'on
a vendu donc au daily mail
oh j'ai aussi dû des analyses avaient il
ya toujours eu un temps 7e est cerné tu
prennes pôle magazine aux états unis qui
paient des millions pour obtenir les
photos exclusives au mariage d'accord et
nous on a toujours été là pour essayer
de casser les activités d'avoir les
photos l'internet actionnariale de
l'astarac te mambé a tancé m
du coup avec myriam haut lieu pour
closer ou pour publiques ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui pour vous vous pouvez
acheter des photos une fortune un
paparazzi pour la mettre du coup pour
réagir très vite sur un site internet
sur le site internet
vous donnez une équivalence une photo
qu'on va payer je sais pas 4 enfin si
j'osais 400 euros pour pour un quart sur
sur le magazine trink va être vendu 2
euros sur le synthé interne et alors
même si à beaucoup de clics a évidemment
donné à 7 2 euros et photographes ne
vendra pas cessé mais l'avait conduit
après là où je suis pas d'accord avec ça
c'est que oui effectivement les réseaux
sociaux ont tué notamment la presse
pourquoi déjà effectivement il dévoile
et dans 10 des voix les normes et voilà
les scoops sinon moi j'aurais aimé y
aura une belle bataille dans le public
était un magazine de beaucoup de télé
réalité on n'en fait plus parce que de
toute façon on entend mieux que ce qu'il
ya sur leurs réseaux sociaux vous être
pour toi mais il ya des accords et
deuxièmement l'autre problème avec les
réseaux sociaux c'est que même si vous
sortez un scoop en couv et vous êtes sûr
de votre info aujourd'hui le people a le
pouvoir avec les abonnés qui l'a de
démentir vos paix sont sortis de vous
pourrir
mais c'est la vérité et sans identité
c'est à une photo de deux personnes qui
s'embrassent qu'est ce que tu veux
qu'ils aillent démenti elles peuvent
dire tu t'étais fait sur une âme mais si
tu as aimé munoz basse sur la photo mais
des fois on n'a pas la photo ac l'homme
n'ont pas la photo faut pas sortir le
scoop déjà leurs confrères tu freines tu
ferais 10 numéros par semaine c'est là
où je rejoins c'est que effectivement la
photo parfaite que toi tu aimes ou les
deux s'embrassent sur la même souvent
vous l'avez pas et du coup vous mettez
un people les l'autre et vous dites ils
sont ensemble et on doit vous croire
désolé je pars du principe que par
exemple si on annonce qu'une nana est
enceinte et qu'après sur les réseaux
sociaux admet que c'est faux et qu'elle
l'ait vraiment pas il fallait attendre
les photos de deux sort alors examiner
ces poulets surgelés tu peux donner la
parole aussi à doter la tant attendue
que j'ai un exemple très concret
rachel rachel pour le cas pour le coup
sûr des réseaux sociaux elle dit je suis
enceinte
bravo et irait pas eu de réseaux sociaux
vous auriez tout doucement vu souvent
grossir et vous en trouve
en 2013 moi-je pour ma première
grossesse contraire but qui avait pas
tout tout tout tout ces réseaux sociaux
aussi développer j'avais vendu l'info à
galles a annoncé les résultats
le contrat n'a plus de budget ils ont
plus d'argent donc c'est bien que ça a
coulé tu peux pas nier si les femmes
pratiquent non je fais le belge il est
pas tout ça les met pas tout je pense
que vous êtes aussi en train de couler
et paparazzi en plus de la presse tout
simplement parce que sur les réseaux
sociaux par tout le monde et on va
paradis n'a pas déçu personne
aujourd'hui sursis à la photo volée dans
la rue n'importe qui saura ce match
allait s'effondrer
magali magali magail l'île aux noix et
message d'ouverture de magazines dans
les cinq dernières années qui ont été
faits qu'un téléphone meilleures nations
mais mettons magali magail et oui mon
chéri
ce que je veux dire et là où je rejoins
sébastien ce qui veut dire c'est que les
vraies enquêtes quand il a fait hollande
c'est quasiment un an dans diète mais ce
qui me pousse ses vraies enquêtes là
c'est pas un mec avec un téléphone sont
appelés couverture légale
ces dernières semaines dans les
magazines des vrais scoops et sap a été
faux téléphones dont s'il vous plaît à
celui qu'il connaît vraiment les stars
arrêter de parler je pense qu'il ya un
jour le même pas ce que ça a tué il ya
quoi il ya cinq magazines people en
france il n'y a aucun cas disparu a
baissé de données si je le mou s'est
mise à fumer avant sont toujours là ok
là les réseaux sociaux ont tué toute la
presse culturelle qui pour le coup a
vraiment disparu il ya plus du tout deux
sur le cinéma sur dix classes a disparu
et il ya un moment il va falloir que le
prix ne sert que les journaux
comprennent il faut forcément faire du
haut de gamme pour se distinguer du bas
de gamme et un exemple très concret ah
pardon mais la sphère rivaux voilà
l'exemple concret voilà qui sort sur
internet ou les réseaux et c'est pas
vous qui l'a vu mais non la presse
people c'est quand même le meilleur tour
autant pour commencer par les ailes par
la couverture de match apparemment c'est
pas quelqu'un qui est qu'il l'a fait
avec un téléphone dont il reste quand
même des c'est la suite les photos de
ces groupes et des salaires on parle de
deux choses différentes
sébastien par des scoops en effet qui
sortent dans la presse le problème de la
presse et que ses ventes ont diminué
avec les réseaux sociaux et les pubs que
qui sont vendus dans la presse se
vendait plus chères que celles qui se
vendent
réseaux sociaux que la presse à une
peste moyens parce que la pub rentrent
moins et les ventes diminuent examens
passés les décès pour reste toujours
dans la presse en revanche les pubs
qu'on achète les bandeaux que vous qu'on
voit dans les six sont vendus une misère
par rapport aux pages de pub qui étaient
achetés et ça qui déséquilibre la presse
et qui fragilise agent john gadret
cinéma est morte depuis longtemps mon
chéri en avant les réseaux sociaux du
carré saint catherine l'annonceur va
préférer prendre nabila pour vendre sa
petite culotte que de prendre une pub
dans un dans un magazine cette réalité
et chassent aussi ça fait partie de
l'économie et c'est pour ça que les
réseaux sociaux ont porté la grand prix
j'ai pu être prêt quand même nom mais
tout ce que tout ce que les stars révèle
d'elle-même comme certains postes en
photo avec leur bébé
du coup tu vas pas être envoyé en asie
pendant la photo du bébé quand elle
passe une photo avec leur nouveau maître
tu vas pas en voyant ma part à
différentes mais moi je dis regardez il
rêvait alors juste avant le fait que
j'ai une question à vous poser je dirai
pas qui mais c'est vrai qu'il me dit a
pas très longtemps il ya un chanteur
très célèbre je les prends en photo je
pense qu'ils en train de sortir avec
machin on dira jamais les noms ici est
ce que cette couv du coup que te répondu
certainement et quelques années
facilement tu arrives à la vendre
aujourd'hui ou pas du tout mais moi
j'arrive toujours avant de mais ce
couple
il n'y a aucun problème là dessus j'ai
pas j'ai pas une baisse de chiffre aimer
mais mes confrères américains ont une
hausse de chiffre mais comprennent en
attendant ils ont eu deux chiffres parce
que les sites comme t'y es mis le daily
mail maintenant on une telle puissance
d'argent et commerciales que ils
achètent des photos mais les photos qui
passe directement sur le net sans passer
par le print eux ont fait la balance
mais ça n'a pas de faiblesse de l'est